[Musique]
élite hommes politiques bonsoir et
bienvenue dans l'hebdo politique votre
rendez vous du dimanche soir sur radio
sensations en association avec tv 78
épisodes 213 mon invité ce soir et le
maire de l'étang la ville daniel cornale
bas
les politiques
daniel cohn alba bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes depuis 2001 le maire de l'étang la
ville vous est également membre du
bureau du mouvement européen et aussi de
celui de l'association des petites
villes de france alors nous aurons le
temps de détailler tout cela au cours de
cette émission mais d'abord j'aimerais
revenir sur vos premiers moments vous
première année en tant que maire depuis
le début vous avez dû gérer la crise
sanitaire ça a été un moment j'imagine
très formateur pour vous c'est le moins
qu'on puisse dire déjà merci de
m'inviter évidemment en tant que maire
on a été sur le front tout du long il
faut se dire qu'on est élu en juin 2020
est donc évidemment on est la deuxième
la troisième la quatrième vague et donc
on a tout de suite voulu va tout
simplement mettre les mains dans le
cambouis
je pense évidemment
la possibilité de faire un centre de
test parce que l'on a on parle de
vaccins aujourd'hui mais à l'époque il
faut se rappeler que l'enjeu essentiel
c'est et les tests et donc c'était se
mettre en capacité à le faire c'était
penser notamment l isolement des plus
anciens c'était penser à nos plus jeunes
je pense à la santé aussi mentale des
jeunes c'est un débat qui est très fort
actuellement mais c'est vrai que sur
tous ces sujets il fallait être sur le
front et on oublie parfois mais que
qu'il y ait ou non confinement une
mairie elle doit continuer à fonctionner
sur toutes ses missions y compris les
contrôles d'urbanisme y compris l'état
civil etc donc c'était vraiment la
mobilisation de tous les agents et là je
crois que faut vraiment faire preuve
d'une capacité à s'adapter et je crois
que c'est la force aussi les petites
villes c'est d'avoir cette proximité
peut-être de déceler plus facilement là
où il ya une difficulté pour une famille
par exemple ce qui serait peut-être plus
compliqué dans une grande ville avec un
certaine anonyme mais on en parlera
peut-être sur le lien par rapport aux
petites villes vous n'avez pas encore 30
ans qu'est ce qui vous avait donné envie
de vous engager en politique
effectivement je vais avoir 30 ans
bientôt pas encore je suis engagé de
longue date dans la vie associative
j'étais déjà membre des jeunes européens
qui sont liens que le mouvement européen
on en dira un mot donc de longue date
j'ai été engagé e de par mes études
voilà c'est le sentiment et la volonté
d'être utile là où on est faire ce que
l'on peut dans le monde associatif
d'abord j'ai été élu en 2014 en tant que
conseiller municipal et on l'a poussé en
2020 de présenter sur une liste à être
tête de cette liste et ma foi j'ai
accepté cet appel que l'on faisait et
puis ma foi on a créé une belle associé
à une belle liste associative on va dire
pour porter pas mal de combat à la fois
sur la démocratie locale sur la
revitalisation des centres-villes sur la
question la transition écologique et
donc je suis depuis maintenant quasiment
deux ans pleinement maire de ma commune
et je crois que c'est l'une des plus
belles fonction qu'on puisse avoir
justement quelles sont les principales
valeurs et convictions que vous allez
défendre tout au long de votre parcours
politique alors dans mon déjà dans mon
mandat je peux me permettre dans les six
ans la queue en cours du mandat il y
avait trois engagements forts je veux
pas être beaucoup plus long et trois
engagements forts la démocratie locale
puisque comme vous le savez peut-être
notre commune avait échappé de peu si je
veux dire à une sorte de fusion
absorption avec une grande ville voisine
dont il y avait un vrai enjeu localement
de démocratie locale et de dire que sur
une décision aussi structurantes il faut
que les la population décide donc il y
avait cet enjeu et qui se transmet
ensuite tout au long de la mandature
dans de la concertation la participation
des citoyens deuxièmement la
revitalisation des coeurs de ville parce
que dans les petites villes un des vrais
enjeux c'est comment maintenir des
commerces comment maintenir des artisans
comment faire vivre une vie culturelle
et sportive et enfin troisièmement c'est
une conviction aussi personnelle c'est
la question la transition écologique
être exemplaire en tant que mairie mais
aussi voilà tout simplement préserver un
environnement qui est assez incroyable
aller dans la ville je sais pas si vous
y avez déjà été montrent que c'est une
sublime ville et donc je disais c'était
les trois points forts j'en ajoute juste
un quatrième qui évidemment que la crise
sanitaire a sauté aux yeux c'est la
question la solidarité je pense qu'on
peut pas faire l'impasse sur les enjeux
de solidarité et on voit vraiment quand
on est maire que la mairie la commune
c'est vraiment le filet de base en
matière aussi de solidarité alors
nouvelle année nouveau en général ça se
fait en présentiel cette année encore
une fois c'est à distance qu avec quelle
formule ce que vous avez choisi alors on
a choisi la vidéo et puis à ma foi les
voeux à l'ancienne aussi je sais pas si
c'est old school mais la carte de voeux
un peu traditionnelle et puis après
aller voir les commerçants allait
discuter avec les associations je crois
beaucoup au contact et c'est vrai que
pas pouvoir le faire de façon physique
c'est un crève coeur donc une autre
façon de faire c'est tout simplement
comme on le fait quasiment tous les
joueurs étoiles terrain les au marché
saluer les gens parce que c'est aussi
comme ça qu'on entend ce qu'ils ont à
nous dire je crois que certains
politiques disait que quand on est mais
on est à portée de baffes on est parfois
aussi apporter de de remontrance ou de
compliment ça dépend mais je pense que
c'est utile de voir les gens quelles
sont les priorités pour les temps la
ville en 2022 il a quelques unes la
priorité il y en a déjà une belle je
pense de toute évidence c'est le cabinet
médical pluridisciplinaire
on a un vrai besoin de médecins ça fait
depuis 2008 au moins qu'on en parle on
va le faire on obtient à priori je le
dis en le disant ici j'espère que ce
sera d'autant plus vrai des financements
de la région de la rs pour pouvoir
mettre en place ce cabinet médical est à
voir comme ça un troisième médecin parce
que c'était un vrai besoin ça c'est une
priorité la deuxième c'est toute la
concertation actuelle sur le devenir du
site scolaire la population augmenter de
plus de 10% qu'il faut adapter nos
équipements mais pas n'importe comment
et donc ça pose des questions est ce
qu'il nous faut les équipements sportifs
comme on l'insère dans son environnement
comme on isole thermiquement et c'est
donc ça ces deux grands sujets
structurants pour les mois qui viennent
on a eu vingt deux il y aura aussi la
fin de la construction de la ligne 13 du
tramway express qui desservira notamment
les temps la ville cette ligne va t'elle
améliorer l'attractivité de la commune
je pense très très nettement une très
belle commune qui est déjà très
attractive on a la chance d'avoir deux
gars sur le territoire ce qui est
exceptionnel on en aura une troisième
j'ai bien conscience que pour une ville
de notre taille c'est assez exceptionnel
aussi
pour dire les choses concrètement on
sera à 15 minutes du centre ville de
saint germain en laye son cinéma
sa piscine le rer a et de l'autre côté
paris du côté de saint cyr et aux portes
de versailles le rer c donc c'est
effectivement beaucoup de facilité
d'usagé je pense que ça va chambouler la
vie de pas mal de monde et on se rend
pas encore assez content je pense que
les gens pour le moment voit les travaux
il voit la ligne c'est ce qui c'est mais
on n'arrive pas encore tout à fait à se
dire ce que ce sera et puis je pense
aussi en terme de tourisme puisque on
sera vraiment à deux pas désormais de la
ferme de gally mais aussi parc du
château de versailles et là je pense que
pour tout un tas aussi de maisons
d'hôtes c'est vraiment un développement
possible touristique qui jusqu'àlors
n'était pas forcément envisageable et
enfin un dernier point où ça peut
changer les choses c'est qu'on sera
relié à des bassins universitaire
surtout si la ligne est poursuivi à
l'avenir vers cergy et donc ça permet
d'envisager parente du logement étudiant
ce qui jusqu'à maintenant aurait été
complètement anachronique faut
complètement décalé par rapport à notre
réalité vous êtes membre du bureau de
l'association des petites villes de
france une association qui existe depuis
1989 pour défendre les intérêts des
villes entre 2500 et 25000 habitants
l'etang-la-ville elle en compte quatre
mille cinq cents environ elle rentre
donc dans cette catégorie alors comment
est ce que vous vous êtes retrouvé à
être membre de ce bureau alors c'est en
effet question importante je précise
quand même ça c'est l'orgueil du style
de vie loi qui parle le chiffre que vous
indiquez sur la population et les
chiffres de l'insee et comme on le sait
cndd au combat on aimerait bien que le
recensement se fasse plus souvent qu'on
a dépassé les 5000 dans les faits mais
ça n'est pas encore reconnue dans les
chiffres mais passons la précision est
temps maintenant je préfère le dire
exactement
la pévèle shu est une très très belle
association j'ai juste deux mots parce
que pour les gens qui nous écoutent ça
peut paraître parfois compliquées entre
la mf toutes ces associations qui
existent pour faire simple association
des maires de france accueillant quelque
sorte quasiment tous les maires de
france quel qu'il soit quel que soit
leur taille de la plus grande à la plus
petite et ensuite pour défendre en
quelque sorte et relayer les
problématiques spécifiques
des villes en fonction de leur taille il
ya des associations dédiées et donc
l'association des petites villes comme
vous l'avez dit et donc c'est sur ce
créneau de 2500 à 25000 qui a vraiment
beaucoup de spécificités moi c'était une
évidence je crois y compris pour notre
ville d'y adhérer précisément parce que
je crois que les habitants sont très
attachés à la taille de commune
c'est-à-dire une ville de proximité une
ville où finalement il ya aussi un
esprit de village qui perdure il ya le
caractère du centre-ville son église ses
vieilles rues c'est une chose mais voilà
il ya quand même un contexte particulier
et est membre de l'ape et vf ça
permettait aussi de relayer vis-à-vis du
parlement vis-à-vis du gouvernement un
certain nombre de problématiques
spécifiques en ce moment si l'explosion
des coûts notamment de l'énergie je
prends juste et exemple là mais il y en
aurait d'autres ça nous permet aussi
d'avoir des informations et de
s'inspirer de ce que font d'autres
villes de la même strate et donc on m'a
proposé d'être membre du bureau
peut-être parce qu'on voulait aussi des
maires je sais pas plus jeunes bon voilà
il ya toute une diversité dans dans la
pbs mais qui vraiment et dans l'ensemble
des départements français et je trouve
que c'est une très très belle structure
et je conseille vraiment si les maires
nous écoutent et qui sont dans cette
strate de nous rejoindre parce que plus
on est plus on pèse plus on est écouté
justement vous parlez de l'énergie
personne n'y a échappé les prix ont
connu une forte augmentation récemment
si les particuliers ont vu les prix être
plafonnés par l'état ce n'est pas le cas
des collectivités quels impacts
justement ça peut avoir sur une petite
commune c'est énorme avec la pdf
justement on a voulu un peu interpellé
le premier ministre
parce que c'est il ya des sujets où on a
des flambées de prix où on n'a pas idée
les particuliers effectivement on eut
droit d un certain nombre d' aide ou de
plafonnement c'est vrai aussi pour les
entreprises on a considéré notamment que
les patrons devaient pouvoir bénéficier
d'un certain nombre de dispositifs on a
étrangement oublié que les maires et les
communes sont aussi les patrons et pas
n'importe lesquels quand même énormément
de personnes qui travaillent en
collectivité et donc on a voulu aussi
donner ce signal d'alarmé dans une
commune comme la mienne le coût
d'énergie sur les coûts d'entretien
courant c'est quasiment 25% donc vous
imaginez que si on a une explosion des
prix de 30% ou plus encore parce que
dans certaines villes on a vraiment des
explosions on atteint des chiffres assez
faramineux ça veut dire très
concrètement dire vous imaginez quand on
dit 25% de notre entretien courant ça
peut aller très vite très haut si c'est
autant d'argent qui est captée sur
l'inflation c'est autant de sous qu'on
n'a pas pour d'autres politiques qui
sont pourtant attendue par les citoyens
donc c'est là où on a vraiment un appel
que nous faisons au gouvernement et je
pense qu'on a bien fait en tant que apf
de s'en saisir et d'être d'ailleurs une
des premières associations de maires à
s'en saisir mais pour l'instant ce qu'
il ya une réponse non on n'en a pas eu
et mme alors j'espère bien puisqu'on a à
nouveau relancer on a appuyé on nous a
dit que il fallait analyser les choses
il faut toujours réaliser mais à un
moment donné il faut aussi agir
il y avait des plafonnements autrefois
un moment ils ont été dérégulé pour tout
un tas de raisons parce que on se
projetait pas dans des crises à venir on
en a presque oublié qu'il pouvait y
avoir à la des fluctuations des prix et
on le paie aujourd'hui donc je pense que
c'est là où on voit d'ailleurs souvent
des choix des décisions qui peuvent
paraître anodines ya quelques années on
peut avoir d'énormes conséquences quand
un moment donné il ya un retournement de
conjoncture et là c'est clairement le
cas aujourd'hui sur l'essence pendant
qu'on y est elles continuent à être
extrêmement rouge chère avec un peu de
recul maintenant est ce que vous trouvez
que la prime de 100 euros qui a été
versée pour les salariés de moins qui
ont gagné moins de 2000 euros c'est une
bonne solution suffisante ou qu'il faut
aujourd'hui d'autres mesures j'ai vu que
d'autres mesures avaient été annoncées
l'atout tout récemment par le premier
ministre bon
moi je viens il faut prendre
effectivement on a dû aménager notamment
pour les agents de la commune nous sait
aussi que jusque là on a payé alors nous
c'était en janvier là où pour la plupart
des des personnes ils ont perçu en
décembre je pense que c'est toujours une
bonne nouvelle dans une période
d'inflation que de faire face à ce
dispositif mais fondamentalement on
pourra toujours aligner des dispositifs
c'est toujours aussi complexe je pense
pour pas mal de personnes ça peut des
vraies questions aussi plus globalement
sur la rémunération quand on parle de
valeur travail c'est comment on rémunère
aussi le travail donc sur ces des vraies
questions autour de ça qu'ils doivent à
mon avis est au coeur des des échéances
à venir vous voyez ce que j'écris je
fais référence il ya quelques débats en
cours je pense qu'il faut vraiment que
ce sujet soit abordé la question du
pouvoir d'achat ou des inégalités peu
importe comme on l'appelle en tout cas
là il ya un vrai sujet est donc là c'est
une réponse mais sans doute y en a bien
d'autres alors vous êtes mère mais vous
êtes également engagé pour le mouvement
européen donc vous êtes membre du bureau
de ce moment est-ce que vous pouvez nous
nous le présenter tout à fait avec grand
plaisir le mouvement européen france
c'est un grand mouvement qui s'est
constitué après guerre par un grand
nombre de citoyens de d'hommes et de
femmes qui se sont dit évidemment après
la déflagration qui a été la seconde
guerre mondiale qu'il fallait se
retrousser les manches pour aussi
essayer de construire la paix très
concrètement créer des ponts entre les
pays tout simplement et donc le
mouvement européen ce n'est pas juste un
mouvement français c'est un mouvement
qui existe quasiment dans toute l'union
européenne est d'ailleurs au delà de
façon assez intéressante et qui ensuite
a des antennes si je dis en national et
ensuite dans chaque département
quasiment vous avez des mouvements
européens mouvement européen c'est quoi
pour faire simple là encore trois idées
fortes la première s'est informé sur le
fonctionnement de l'union européenne et
de l'europe plus généralement on sait
que c'est compliqué et pour pouvoir en
débattre c'est déjà bien de connaître
les règles on parle beaucoup en ce
moment la présidence française du
conseil de l'union européenne je suis à
peu près certain que la plupart des gens
qui nous écoutent ne savent pas ce qu
elle conseille enfin tout simplement de
l'union européenne donc c'est expliquer
le fonctionnement premièrement donc y
compris interventions dans les écoles
organisation de conférences
production d'un certain nombre
d'éléments de brochures pour informer à
l'échelle vraiment de tout le pays
deuxièmement c'est faire naître un débat
sur l'europe que l'on veut il ya
régulièrement des débats mais c'est
important qu'il se tienne on peut avoir
des visions différentes et ce qui est
intéressant c'est que le mouvement
européen n'est pas un parti c'est une
association on peut d'ailleurs
d'horizons différents et en être membre
et le but c'est de dire on a des
différences mais on peut avoir des
visions alternatives de ce que doit être
l'europe et ben on en débat ça c'est un
point essentiel et je crois que ce
mouvement fait vivre le débat en france
et après troisièmement c'est faire des
propositions nous mêmes sur la base de
ces débats de ces informations de dire
comment on peut peut-être démocratiser
davantage encore l'union européenne à
rendre plus compréhensible plus
accessible plus efficace encore il y
aurait pas mal de sujets qu'on peut
évoquer mais c'est vraiment les trois
piliers de ce mouvement est là dans la
campagne présidentielle notamment un de
nos enjeux c'est d'interpeller les
candidats et de dire bon bah par exemple
sur l'europe quelle est votre position
on a eu les positions de certains pas de
tous donc c'est important que chacun
s'exprime eq en connaissance de cause
après les élections on sache qui gage
sur quoi pour vous aujourd'hui qu'est ce
qu'elle représente l'union européenne
alors elle représente énormément de
choses à la fois c'est des institutions
ont sous-estimé je pense à quel point
elles ont évolué et qu'elle se sont
démocratisés le rôle du parlement
européen est devenu assez central on
sait que simone veil en a été la
présidente mais depuis l'époque où elle
en était la présidente et aujourd'hui il
ya eu un nombre de pouvoirs conséquent
qui ont pu être attribuées moi je trouve
que la commission européenne donc quasi
gouvernements européens en tout cas clé
lui les institutions européennes se sont
largement politisé c'est une bonne chose
est ce que je trouve intéressant c'est
qu'ils y compris les partis d'extrême
droite est clairement vous comprendrez
que je n'en suis pas
j'entends que ceux là même qui disait il
faut sortir d'une européenne il faut
sortir de l'euro c'est plus le discours
qu'on entend aujourd'hui c'est plus un
discours qui s'assume politiquement
alors d'autres critiques qui peuvent
être faites mais c'est intéressant que
le débat a quand même évolué maintenant
sont foncièrement ma conviction c'est
que l'union européenne pourrait être
acceptée pour être précise le mot c'est
de dire aimer elle a besoin d'être
efficace elle a besoin d'être comprise
et moi je pense sincèrement que par
exemple dans la mondialisation dont le
commerce extérieur dans la lutte contre
le dérèglement climatique pour donner
juste ces quelques exemples là on peut
agir en tant que france évidemment mais
le poids que l'on a en tant qu'union
européenne avec plus de 400 millions
d'européens change fondamentalement la
donne si vous négocier un contrat ou un
traité avec les états unis si vous êtes
67 millions versus 320 millions c'est
pas tout à fait la même chose que 300
vient versus plus de 400 avec une europe
qui sous-estiment je pense à puissance
potentielle à la fois son incapacité
en termes de pouvoir d'achat son
influence possible et je dis juste un
mot là-dessus
je pense qu'un vrais enjeux il ya
différentes conceptions de ce que doit
devenir le notre monde notre planète il
ya plusieurs visions du monde et je
pense qu'en tant qu'européens on en a
une qui notamment fondée sur la dignité
humaine de tous les êtres humains sur
l'état de droit ce qui est loin d'être
quand on regarde le chez nous dans notre
pays c'est loin d'être acquis la
question de l'état de droit et je crois
aussi une conviction qu'il faut une
trajectoire qui nous fasse respecter les
accords de paris de 2015 rien que sur
ces trois points là je pense que
l'europe a une voix singulière dans le
monde il faut qu'elle la défendent et à
27 on sera toujours plus fort que tout
seul depuis le 1er janvier la france est
là et présidente du conseil de l'union
européenne
est-ce que selon vous les grands médias
français parle t'il assez de cette perf
comme on l'appelle
à ce qu'ils en parlent assez on peut
toujours en parler plus j'ai vu qu'on a
beaucoup parlé drapeau c'est déjà ça au
moins tout le monde connaît la couleur
du drapeau et la première polémique
exactement le but de l'année non mais je
dis ça en plaisantant puisque je trouve
que c'est un sujet somme toute second
fin ce n'est pas le fond du sujet
la problématique que l'on a aujourd'hui
c'est qu'on a une plaie furieux que vous
dites donc présidence française du
conseil de l'union européenne qui
tournent en même temps que l'élection
présidentielle donc c'est sûr que ça va
gris zié et que le temps utile pour
cette présidence elle va forcément être
un petit peu raboté puisque un moment
donné je ne connais pas je suis pas dans
le secret voilà mais il est probable que
ans au coeur de l'élection quand tout le
monde se sera déclarée candidat il sera
plus forcément possible d'être
totalement au travail au niveau européen
par contre je pense qu'à énormément de
combats à mener on a parlé la question
du salaire minimum européen on a parlé
d'un certain nombre de directives et
d'objectifs en matière de dérèglement
climatique il ya plein de sujets où
cette présidence est attendue l'accueil
jeunes manquent pas exactement
l'actualité manquent pas au niveau
européen sur quasiment tous les sujets
et donc je pense qu'on a besoin d'une
présidence forte qui impulsent des idées
j'ai l'impression que c'est la
conviction actuel qui portait par le
gouvernement moi je pense que l'idéal
aurait été qu'on ait une présidence
pleine et entière pendant six mois elle
sera forcément morcelé on connaît pas le
résultat des élections présidentielles
donc il y aura aussi deux temps c'est
aussi compliqué pour nos partenaires
européens et on l'a vu tout récemment
parlement européen que je finalement
voilà le débat présidentiel s'immisçait
même dans le parlement européen ce qui
est assez inédit donc voilà je pense que
on va finalement plus par l'élection
présentielle que l'union européenne ça
c'est sans doute dommage mais à nous de
faire en sorte qu'on parle d'europe dans
l'élection présidentielle est ce que
vous avez senti une dynamique qui s'est
créée depuis c'est le 1er janvier le
début de cette présidence à ce qu'on
parle plus d'europe qu'avant en tout cas
c'est clair que de toute façon dans la
presse dans les médias on en parle
davantage ça oblige aussi un certain
nombre de candidats
poser concrètement leur vision des
religions on a vu à strasbourg
exactement comme ça c'est le point
positif c'est que ça oblige tout le
monde à dire bague si je suis élue
qu'est ce que je fais sur l'europe donc
ça à la rigueur tant mieux est ce que je
constate c'est que la mobilisation n'est
pas que politique elle est aussi
associative elle est aussi dans tout un
tas dans la société civile comme on dit
moi je vois beaucoup d'associations qui
ne sont pas forcément engagée sur
l'europe à la base qui se disent bah
tiens voilà je vais organiser telle
conférence où je vais essayer de mettre
en visibilité
je pense par an à beaucoup de porteurs
de projets qui font l'objet de
financements européens et qui sont
souvent financées par les villes par les
intercoms les départements les régions
et aussi par l'union européenne là il y
en a pas mal qui nous disent bas on veut
pour le mois de mai qui est un peu le
mois de l'europe faire des portes
ouvertes que les gens découvrent on sait
pas toujours que l'union européenne
parle finances assez massivement
d'ailleurs par des politiques sociales
aussi la réinsertion notamment des
jeunes dans l'emploi la question des
quartiers populaires il ya énormément de
financement qui sont mis sur la table
qui sont trop souvent ignoré c'est
l'occasion aussi d'en parler et dire que
l'europe en vérité elle peut être social
elle peut être écologique a faim il peut
être beaucoup de choses en tout cas elle
finance énormément et parfois sur les
territoires c'est un partenaire décisif
alors la critique revient sur le
financement c'est que l'europe finance
des projets mais que finalement c'est
l'argent de la france puisqu'elle est
contributrice nette est ce que oui alors
c'est ce qui est intéressant parce que
c'était un des arguments pour le bric
site donc au royaume uni on avait cet
argument là aussi il est juste une
information qui est tombée je crois
cette semaine qui est assez intéressante
c'est que depuis que le royaume uni a
quitté l'union européenne les
financements directs aux territoires aux
collectivités ont baissé donc c'est
intéressant parce que la grande bretagne
passé son temps aussi à dire ça c'est à
dire mais finalement nous prendre notre
argent dans une poche on nous donne
quelque chose dans une poche manga les
deux t on ne l'a pris dans l'autre donc
en fait on s'y retrouve pas c'est
intéressant de voir qu'en fait quand on
est dans l'union européenne ont réfléchi
à plusieurs sur justement quelles sont
les priorités qu'on se donne
collectivement pour le monde rural par
exemple que la priorité qu'on se donne
pour les quartiers populaires quelle est
la priorité qu'on se donne pour la
réindustrialisation
quelles sont les normes collectives
qu'on se donne pour éviter qu'ils du
dumping social du dumping fiscal etc je
pense qu'il faut aller plus loin mais
c'est intéressant de se dire que déjà on
réfléchit à plusieurs et que quand un
pays quitte l'union européenne au monde
m'attend dans cet exemple là on constate
que cela qu'ils disaient mais attendez
n'y a pas assez d'argent pour notre
hôpital n'y a pas assez d'argent pour
nos territoires finalement depuis qu'ils
en sont partis il y en a encore moins ce
qui pose une vraie question au royaume
uni sur la répartition des richesses ça
c'est à la rigueur leurs problématiques
mais preuve que l'union européenne peut
être un vrai levier d'action et moi je
dirai juste un sujet mois pour moi la
problématique sur les financements c'est
pas tant celui que vous avez évoquées
pour moi le vrai sujet c'est d'aller les
récupérer que c'est pas acceptable que
vous ayez des enveloppes budgétaires
qu'ils soient pas utilisés à 100% parce
que souvent c'est trop complexe
notamment les collectivités je pense aux
petites villes se sont un peu démunis
parce que on va pas on n'a pas les
moyens de recruter de façon dédié une
personne qui va faire que les
financements européens les demandes de
secondes exactement parce que ça a un
coût moi ce que je plaide ça dépend
toujours la taille des communes mes
parents mais une commune comme la mienne
c'est qu'au niveau d'une
intercommunalité c'est le cas dans la
nôtre saint-germain boucles de seine on
se dise bastien on a un projet de
territoire on a un plan climat qu'on est
en train de développer ensemble on a des
projets dans chacune de nos villes
pourquoi pas demander tout simplement
aussi à la communauté d'agglomération
d'être ce levier là et finalement on
répartit le coût du recrutement de
quelqu'un qui va pouvoir avoir cette
expertise pour aller chercher les
financements moi tout seul mais projet
aurait pas des montants très élevés
l'intérêt l'attractivité peut-être pour
l'union européenne serait moindre quand
on est comme c'est notre cas à plus de
trois cent mille habitants là tout de
suite on arrive sur des montants
conséquents et on a plus de chance de
toucher ses financements et donc je suis
content que c'est justement la voie que
que prend notre agglo étant moi même au
sein de l'agglo en charge notamment la
nature en ville la préservation des
forêts il ya pas mal dans le jeu en
termes de financement sur ces sujets là
et donc je suis content qu'on ait fait
ce choix collectifs qui j'espère nous
rapportera des financements et donc du
service public supplémentaire pour nos
habitants selon l'eurobaromètre viavoice
pour france info 65% des français
souhaiteraient être mieux informés sur
l'union européenne et surtout sur les
réalisations concrètes de cette dernière
comme les subventions dont vous avez
parlé en tant que maire de l'étang la
ville laquelle retour ce que vous avez
des habitants est ce que vous sentez
un intérêt particulier pour l'union
européenne et pour ces questions alors
moi je triche un tout petit peu parce
que dans ma ville c'est le cas dans
beaucoup de villes il ya une vraie
diversité européenne très très
importante parce que on est une ville
qui à la frontière entre le monde rural
et en même temps on est une des
dernières villes si j'ose dire dans la
zone urbaine où l'agglomération
parisienne en quelque sorte après c'est
le pourtour de la forêt de marly et
ensuite une zone un peu plus rurales je
lui ai pas dit tout à l'heure mais deux
tiers de mon territoire c'est de la
forêt donc tout simplement pour vous
dire qu'on est vraiment à cette frange
là et donc finalement on a pas mal de
personnes qui
d'origine diverse européenne mais au
delà habite ma commune puis parce qu'on
a la proximité du lycée international de
saint germain en laye juste à côté on a
un certain nombre de grandes entreprises
et des lignes de train qui nous amène à
la défense à paris donc on a une vraie
diversité européenne non je pense que le
sujet européen est peut-être déjà
davantage compris et canton j'organisais
en tant que responsable à l'époque du
mouvement européenne une fête de
l'europe pour un certain nombre de
conférences généralement n'avait salle
comble je sais que ce n'est pas le cas
partout donc je pense que quand vous
avez dit tout à l'heure les français
souhaiteraient être mieux informés je
les comprends totalement je pense que
c'est notre rôle en tant qu'association
mais c'est collectivement peut-être rôle
des mères le rôle des responsables
politiques d'être capable d'expliquer
cela la vérité c'est que les maires et
les élus sont parfois eux mêmes assez
peu formés sur le fonctionnement de
l'union européenne est encore au congrès
des maires de france en novembre dernier
quand j'en parlais avec des collègues
c'était intéressant beaucoup disaient
sur les financements européens j'ai
vaguement une idée de checchi toqués
pour obtenir des sous par contre qu'est
ce que la commission européenne à quoi
sert le parlement européen qu'elle
qu'est ce que le conseil de l'union
européenne souvent il ya des mélanges
quand on rajoute le conseil de l'europe
le conseil européen les gens se
mélangent et c'est vrai que il faut le
reconnaître les noms les mots se
ressemblent tellement qu'à la fin les
gens ne comprennent pas trop et je pense
d'ailleurs y aurait sans doute un choc
de simplification affaire là à faire
vendredi 11 février la maison de
l'europe des yvelines célébrera ses 20
ans elle est membre de la fédération
française des maisons de l'europe
elle même qui est membre du mouvement
européen france elle a pour objectif de
réduire le fossé qui peut exister entre
les institutions européennes et des
chenils locale il ya aujourd'hui une
trentaine de maisons de l'europe partout
en france est ce que ce sont des
initiatives qu'il faudrait développer
encore plus ah oui je soutiens à 100% la
maison de l'europe des yvelines que je
salue je salue évidemment sa présidente
salue sa directrice qui sont évidemment
pas loin de l'étang la ville donc on les
connaît bien mais
c'est vraiment un incroyable support à
la fois pour les citoyens faut savoir
tout citoyen qui toquent à la porte
parce qu'il veut des renseignements qui
veut s'inscrire à la newsletter ou que
sais-je pour avoir des infos peut les
avoir c'est un partenaire essentiel pour
les collectivités précisément pour être
au courant des financements qui existent
peut-être des écueils à éviter
on a là une équipe à la fois de
permanents mais aussi de bénévoles qui
est assez incroyable qui en soutien on
parlait du mouvement européen tout à
l'heure mais c'est un partenaire évident
je pense à la maison de l'europe de
paris je pense à de nombreuses maisons
de l'europe en france si on n'a pas dans
tous les départements mais dans beaucoup
de départements et oui c'est un soutien
colossal de l'essentiel merci beaucoup
d'années merci à vous pour le temps
d'avaler le sacré avec nous se rappelle
que vous êtes le maire de l'étang la
ville et nous on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro de
l'hebdo politique
[Musique]